like left being human faith got a job
with myself but declined it
out of integrity opened up your eyes
researched
hustled went to auctions drove to
liverpool from london
you know fair play man fair respect
and now i've accumulated using other
people's money
a large portfolio hey what's up guys
welcome back to my channel welcome to
a winners on a wednesday episode where
i'm gonna be
interviewing a serial entrepreneur who's
become very successful in property
he's accumulated 13 houses that he now
owns
was working at b and q now is very
successful and in this interview he's
going to be
explaining and revealing exactly how he
did that
through strategies like joint ventures
you're gonna learn a ton of information
take good notes make sure you like the
video subscribe if you're not already
subscribed
and until that time hey welcome to
winners on a wednesday thank you staff
having me
really good so you literally came to the
crash course a couple years ago
yeah it was june 2019 june 2019
and you'll never forget the dates
what happened so basically i went up
there and so it was uh
it was a long day it was two days yes it
was from eight o'clock in the morning
because i think it was ten at night
right and tons and tons of information
and so you know it was just taking in
all of that information
and kind of then afterwards processing
it but it was really enjoyable i thought
before i went to the crashes i thought
you know it's gonna be a really really
long day you know how am i gonna manage
but actually it went fairly quickly yeah
and i wanted kind of
you know more
that's the thing people do get worried
they're like and they know with me
i can go on until anytime like you could
go until midnight
but actually the reason it goes on is
not because it's boring lectures because
we're doing deals
we're networking we're on the phone so
okay so when you came to the crash
course
you had one property and you were
working at b and q
uh well uh i
just left being q in june oh wow
in faith or what yeah in faith in
in terms of yeah you know it was a big
risk
but i i wanted to take that risk because
i've been in retail i was in retail for
over 20 years
yeah kind of i just had enough
and i want to do something different and
property i was thinking about it
for a couple of years before i actually
went ahead with it
but it was a case of um you know you've
got lots of
responsibility how do i take that step
take that leap
yeah and i think when i started research
and i came across your videos your
youtube channel
and uh kind of
edged me on really edged me off now
something really interesting
was that in june when you came to the
crash course you just quit your job you
came on the crash course
and we offered you
a job yes talk to me about that
yeah yeah so basically you were coming
down from
i think you were based in birmingham at
that point or medium dairy you're coming
to london yeah so i think one of your
youtube videos you said
uh you know if you're interested in
applying for a job you know
we're coming back to london applied blah
blah blah and so i said you know what
if this was after the crash was actually
because i just wanted to be around
your team because i just found it so you
know you're full of improved enthusiasm
you know
it's just for me it was amazing so i
thought you know what i'm just gonna
send my cv
so i sent my cv and i think sarah uh
contacted me i went for an interview and
then after that
she phoned me up she offered me a job
she loved your energy
she thought you'd be a good asset to the
team but you had like a guilt trip right
there i did
yeah because at that point i wanted to
buy properties i wanted to
obviously invest i wanted to kind of
build a portfolio and i'm thinking
actually
if i take the job i'm not going to give
a hundred percent yeah and it's not
really
fair not to give a hundred percent and
then kind of i then
spoke to sarah and i said you've got
this situation i don't think i can give
you hundred percent and it's not gonna
be fair
yeah and i respect that because you
applied for the job
kind of really and and we try and look
out for this i try and spot this
people but sometimes you can't and
obviously sarah missed it but when
people are applying for the job
just because they want to be around me
and the team and whatever
usually they'll be disappointed anyway
because unless you happen to be darwin
and you're with me filming
unless you're a videographer you
probably won't see me that often anyway
you'll be
in an office somewhere so you know um
but that's great so you apply for a job
turned it down after being accepted had
one property left being queued in faith
where did this fire come from what age
were you why did you suddenly just go
i don't want to work at baq anymore i
want to be a property investor like what
happened
i'm actually 42 years old but you look
very good for 42.
so you're like 40 at the time i was
fully at the time so i mean
i have always um like i said i've been
in retail
i've always for the last 20 years been
in management
and i've worked really hard i've earned
you know a lot of money
um but i missed
a lot of my children growing up so i've
got three dollars
so so in terms of uh you know them
growing up i
missed a lot there growing up you didn't
go to the school place because i was
focused on my career i was focused on
actually
doing a great job and moving up to earn
the big salary
but actually you know there comes your
point graphic actually
it's it's this it's not it i want i want
more
you know more time off quality time yeah
and that's how it's kind of started and
then
my wife got pregnant again um and then i
thought no i've got to leave now you
know
but i don't want to do the same thing as
i done with my daughters yeah
too much to my baby so so what you got
now i've got three four i've got four
now oh wow
or three year old son now congrats okay
so
turn four a bang wife pregnant with a
fourth
about to have a son and you're just
thinking i don't want to be working this
hard
miss my my next kid's you know childhood
absolutely yeah you just think forget it
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
quit my job and i'm gonna in take the
risk and hopefully succeed in property
now what you've achieved since over the
last two years has been remarkable i
mean you've built up a property
portfolio
of 13 houses which you own your company
owns you've also bought
other properties on top of that which
you've bought and you've sold and made a
profit
yeah and that's uh joint venture
partners right
so so where did the money come from to
buy
this many houses okay so basically over
the years
i saved quite a bit of money yeah
because obviously i was in a good job of
getting a good salary yeah obviously i
was getting bonuses etc so i saved
quite a bit of money so when i first um
bought my first property and this was
before the crash course this was before
the crash
yeah um so i bought it with that um
and then i went to the crash course and
then
i'm thinking you know you you you are
giving out loads of information about
you know costings etc etc and then
you you talked about joint ventures and
i'm thinking in my head it's going round
and round thinking actually
because my money's going to run out you
know there's going to be a certain point
where it's going to run out yeah what am
i going to do how am i going to grow my
portfolio i'm going to grow my houses
i'm going to grow my business
and that's when it kind of started
clicking joint venture joint venture
partners
well you know use other people's money
you know leverage and all of that kind
of stuff
that's intelligent intelligent and the
thing is if you don't remind me asking
how much money did you have to put into
that first property how much did you
save up
yeah so i had about 70 000 pounds sure
did you put that all into a proper chair
not all of it how much did you put in i
so my first property was a flat and i'm
putting 36 000 pounds cool
so oh wow yeah so where'd you buy it
from an auction and you bought it cash
for 36.
that's cheap bro right
now it wasn't chewed a house oh my
goodness
oh my goodness so you're buying like the
houses in my apartment block
and then you go into oh my goodness i
know i know i've got a lot of i got a
lot of apartments
uh i saw this now though how much you
sell it for 57
boom shaka and i had it rented for a
year and a half for about 450
no 475 okay okay okay so you come on my
turf
right you come on my turf you buy my
houses so we use london as taking all
our houses
right all right so you bought that
really cheap at auction but my
my um and then you sold it for how much
57 so you made a little bit of profit
pay paid um paid stamp duty and whatnot
but still made a little bit profit
second property that you bought how much
you have to put down
so my second property was a refurb
and that was in wolverhampton again dude
you're stealing my turf but that's
okay in particular no way
mate mate okay how much you pay for it
i paid 85 000 for it you still own it no
i sold that how much you sell it for i
sold it for 132.
and and did you have to refurb it yeah
how much thousands so you made about
how much profit we made about just over
thirty thousand and did you use your
money to do that
no that was joint venture okay cool
so so the thing is though these types of
deals right
you need a bit of money to save up
35 grand or 70 grand in your kind of job
again if you don't want me asking how
much were you on your salary so my base
was 65.
okay so you're on decent salary but
again you've got to save
half of your salary just to get
enough to buy the cheapest flat every
morsel
for a year so you you're kind of
thinking at the crash course that's the
slow way
yeah yeah so then you start so that was
my first one in wall street
yeah i come to the crash course yeah
then you talk about joint ventures
right and then you talk about actually
use other people's money
you've reached there's loads of ways you
know take physics profit you keep your
time
you use their money and that's kind of
then spiraled
yeah so then what you basically start
using the same strategy
clearly even before the crash course you
knew how to do a good deal
you knew how to negotiate a good deal
yes
but i've got to say i started watching
your youtubes
probably from beginning of 2019.
yeah so a lot of that knowledge
sure got you yeah came from a lot of
your youtube videos got you
got it that's awesome man i appreciate
you saying that because it makes me feel
good because you know i understand it
because you're in front of me yeah
it actually happened yeah my wife i
remember my wife was looking outside
she said what you didn't watch it and i
at that point i was obviously still
working
for watching i'm like i'm watching
something he's saying
he's a property like mogul you know yeah
i'm watching your mom trying to get up
at us writing stuff down
yeah and and yeah so let's call that man
so stop watching youtube
learn about negotiating a good deal save
a little money
start doing property come to the crash
course was that like
that that was like a bomb yeah
sometimes people say there's no point
traveling to the crash course because
all the contents online
no you you can't for me
having it live is even better
yeah yeah because what you did was
during the crash course you actually
started phoning estate agents live
and stuff you know stuff like that and
you you put us in groups and
um maybe that's a little bit
uncomfortable yeah but you know what
that does that
brings you out the shell and makes you
comfortable
in a weird way yes so so kind of that
does 100 help you on training
what area did i suggest that you go to
you
right so and this is god's honest truth
god i have
no aspect of going into liverpool before
i came to a crash course because i was
thinking because my brother lives in
birmingham
so i was looking at that area from a
logistics point of view because i was
thinking actually if there's any issues
my brother just helped me out
right now so so that's probably why i
started off in the midlands
but then when you talked about liverpool
i'm thinking actually
let me do a bit of research and then
when i started researching you know
there's millions of pounds going into
liverpool you know
as an area yeah um rejuvenating the area
et cetera so
then i went up to liverpool and kind of
kind of
drove about saw houses etc and
if you remember at the time at the crash
course around 2019
there was a lot of newspaper articles i
think i spoke about this at the crash
course that was saying liverpool's about
to crash
yes and i'm like guys it ends
you you actually said actually
liverpool's lag
behind liverpool's gonna catch up yeah
yeah he's about to vote
and then the houses that you bought in
liverpool have they boomed
at the moment it is just crazy prices
yeah crazy absolutely talk to me about
some of the figures so
for example even when i started so my
first book i bought liverpool was for 51
250 pounds yeah yeah on the same street
now you can't get any houses cheaper
than 75 000 pounds
so the appreciation has been like 25
percent
just within the last two years actually
that's more that's like almost like 50
percent increase
50 to 75 over the last couple of years
so
capital appreciation good and not only
that the rental increase as well
so the first property i bought at croco
street i remember that street
uh i was renting that for four to five
yeah
now i'm getting 495. wow so rents have
gone up
it just shows that the media was so
wrong when they were saying
but the thing is the media were getting
their information from estate agents
and estate agents were saying
liverpool's about to crash
because they wanted homeowners to sell
their houses
before the crash because the estate
agents wanted more stock
because they didn't have enough stock
for the investors that were desperate to
buy houses
so all the agents are telling the media
oh it's about to crash
so that what happens is everyone gets
scared and wants to sell their houses
meanwhile actually it's rising fake
news i'm saying this at the time i'm
saying fake news
meanwhile houses are going up my
students to people like yourself
who have to give it to you bro like left
being queueing faith
got a job with myself but declined it
out of integrity
opened up your eyes researched hustled
went to auctions drove to liverpool from
london
you know fair play man fair respect
and now i've accumulated using other
people's money
a large portfolio but what i want to say
really important because people have
seen now on youtube
you're doing this in liverpool i
interviewed crept recently
uh famous uk rapper um he's killing it
in liverpool
liverpool is not a magic area like
there's a lot of
terrible areas of liverpool that you do
not want to touch in a barge pot
there are also parts of liverpool that
are terrible investment areas
or like it it's you can make money
pretty much anywhere
but you need to really work hard you
need to know your numbers you need to
know how to work out the roi
you need to know how to risk assess talk
to me a little bit about that
so again when i talk about earlier on
when i talk about knowledge and that's
where the knowledge bit comes in
yeah and so you if you want to go and
invest in a particular area
you need to know what you're looking for
you need to know what you're researching
you need to know what's like you said
there's back within the area there's
good and bad post roads so which are the
postcodes you're going to
go into so that's all of that again
you're not just going to learn it off it
you need to get knowledge and that's
where you know
kind of even in your crash course you
gave a lot of that knowledge
yeah so talk to me then how do you
calculate
what are the things that you look for
when you view a house what are some of
the things you need to be really
mindful of so in terms of financials
first of all i
i go backwards i work at the financials
first so return on investment
yeah is it going to be worth my while
buying this property because
my in particular liverpool what i do is
i rent most of the properties
i don't resell them right and so i rent
them out so i look at
return on investment so i know you talk
about 20
for you yeah but i look at about 15 15
percent
that's good that's good but then it also
depends how conservative you are
so if you work out your numbers really
conservatively and it's 15
that's fine so that's good though um
what else do you look for what what do
you look for
in the actual house itself so for me
i look at where you can potentially add
value as well so a lot of my properties
are two bedroom properties that can be
turned into three bedrooms how can they
be turning through them because there's
that opportunity if you move flat for
example
if you move the bathroom around right um
so currently i've got quite a few two
bedroom properties where by the
the bathrooms upstairs you've got two
bedrooms upstairs
and there's potentially you can move the
bathroom downstairs and make a
three-bedroom property
um so those are the kind of things it
all depends on what you want to do
there's opportunities for hmos folks
i've got a hmo in liverpool so there's
opportunities for hashtags
very good at least i i need i've leased
that to a company
they're paying me a flat rate for 1100 a
month okay good
and they pay all the bills etcetera yeah
yeah yeah and how much you buy that for
i bought that for 115 000. you went for
115
you're getting 1 100 very good yields
all bills paid so return worried about
nothing that must be returning close to
20 percent
that's 20 yeah yeah 19 okay good
so how then so you came to the crash
course
you learned how to find deals area stuck
a deal
everything how did you manage to find
joint venture partners
so for me it was kind of once i finished
the crash course once i looked into the
joint ventures it's about
one of the things you talked about in
your crash course is actually
talk to everyone about what you do yes
tell everyone what you do whether they
invest or they don't take notes just
tell them tell them what you do and
that's how i started
i talked to everybody about what i'm
doing um i
instagram i opened up my instagram page
uh and then kind of i was it properties
i was viewing i was putting up
property that i owned it was at that
point i was one property
you know going on to another one so i
was so
literally talking to everyone facebook
on my personal i was just saying
so people reach out to you friends
family colleagues whoever
and they say that sounds interesting how
can i get involved
what do you say and that's when i start
talking about actually
you know what is it what you know and
find out what what they're
needing what they're requiring and
that's kind of how it started and then
what all right i'm looking oh that
sounds really interesting how could we
do a deal what are you
what are you proposing to the joint
venture party my joint venture partners
in terms of the deals it depends on what
they're doing so not
uh not every deal is the same yes yeah
so it depends on the person it depends
on how much money they're putting in etc
so
again what do they want do they want a
long-term investment do they want a
short-term investment
so that's kind of you then go into a
little bit more detail in terms of what
they're doing what they want what they
what they want to do with the money
makes sense and again i say this at the
crash course
a joint venture is a blank piece of
paper it's not
a one-size-fits-all and you're right you
should listen to what they're looking to
do
and then find a deal specifically to
suit their needs let them put the money
in
split the profits boom and reinvest that
profit
yes if you were to start all over again
from scratch
with no money no job nothing
what would you do i would
invest find some money and invest in
myself
okay yeah why would you say that because
again if i
had no knowledge yeah i had no money i
had no job i had no knowledge
how am i gonna go and invest okay i want
to invest
in there what about if you did have your
knowledge now okay so so so you're
starting all over again from scratch
you've got no money yeah you've got no
nothing but you've got your knowledge
and everything like that you just
start with no money but you've got your
knowledge okay what do you do
i would then reach out to get joint
venture partners right so basically
exactly what we did
yeah we do it again i'll do it again and
you can keep on doing it
so what would you say to somebody that
said to you
i'd love to build a property empire and
have a dozen houses or so like you've
done
but i haven't got any money is it
possible absolutely it is
absolutely is uh and again it's
about how you're gonna go and do it yeah
um and again i go back to the bit about
you need to get that understanding and
that
knowledge it is so important it is
something because i know a lot of people
that started in property
and they burnt themselves because they
didn't really know what they're doing
yeah
um so absolutely it's possible but
you need the foundations which is the
knowledge bit what
um do you do deal sourcing i don't know
i do
is there a reason you should quick quick
cash
it is quick cash but you know with the
deal so i'm thinking actually if it's a
good deal
i'm in a position where i can do that
deal myself
but you can just borrow the money yes
that's that's true and and i'm thinking
why am i gonna then you know i mean if
he's gonna make me money
and to be honest i could do dual
sourcing because there's loads of deals
that come
come through yeah but i just do it
myself i don't
you know i mean so because i'm not
thinking just short term i'm thinking
medium term as well i think here's what
i think
thomas it depends on what that the
person's
goal is yes if your goal is to make
three grand this month
then deal sourcing is great if your goal
is to build long-term wealth
like what you're doing generational
wealth for the kids right
then what you're doing is great um apart
from the kids
um what's your strongest reason for
doing this
i think it was just a different life i
mean i was working
50 to 60 hours a week yeah you know
during my days off i was taking calls
during my holidays i was going into my
store to see how it's running
right and it wasn't a great life
yeah you know i mean it wasn't and i'll
be honest and i i re
looking back at what you know how i
moved up in the
ladder i regret it in terms of i lost a
lot of
quality time without you man it's funny
because
everybody aspires to progress but when
you're in a job
often the higher you get up the more you
progress the more work you have to do
so everyone's aspiring to progress they
might be getting paid a little bit more
like you were getting paid really well
for retail sick like 60 grand or
whatever
that's really really good for for a
retail management job
but then you're working 60 70 hours
you you're taking over your life you
can't see your kids
you don't need to work that hard to make
that much money if you're going to work
hard anyway
you may as well get rich absolutely
which is what you're doing right now
so what does your family think your wife
kids
yeah so it's a strange one you know and
i was thinking you know
in terms of when i started off i i'll be
honest i didn't get
full support from my other half oh yeah
yeah yeah she was like you're earning
this much money like why did you wanna
you know what
what you doing yeah and i was like you
got trust you got trust him you've got
trust in what i'm doing you've got to
trust me yeah and i mean i'm doing this
because of
us you know i mean but then when i
started doing it
especially i think she saw a massive
change in me once i
came out of the crash course and then i
had full support from her
i think the initial bit was what you
what you're doing
why was that thing what did you reckon
after the crash course so it switched
because i went i
probably went from 60 to 70 percent
in terms of driving like i mean 250
interesting you know what's really
interesting about that as well i find
that often people's partners don't
support them
when they don't even fully believe it
themselves
so and what happens on when you come to
some of the training crash course or
whatever
there's a switch in you and someone's at
the crash course even in the crash
course people are saying
oh before i fully commit i just need to
get my wife on board i'm like no
you need to get fully on board you need
to you need to want to do this you need
to burn the bridges
so you can't go back and when you do
that your wife or husband or whoever
will respect your passion
your commitment your dedication and
they'll have no choice
but to jump on on board and that's what
you did right you made a decision for
yourself
and then she jumped on board yeah
although i had a bit of a if where in
the beginning
[Music]
be careful be careful all the skeptical
voices
yeah i just i do i think you believe in
yourself
yeah and i think if you if you're really
determined
to make a difference if you're really
determined to do this
then just do it yeah just do it yeah you
know
um but do it in the right way yeah
totally man
what would you say has been the biggest
change
in your everyday life between now and
two years ago how's life different
the biggest change is the amount of time
i can spend with my son
yeah that is the biggest you know i and
and the stress as well is the biggest
difference because when i was working it
was a very stressful job it was
it was you know and it's a different
kind of stress but it's an
it's it's a lot better stress now
yeah you know i'm stressing now about
okay how do i find my next deal
to make money you know i mean yeah
whereas the stress i had
previously it was totally different it
was like god i'm gonna get a story is it
i need to make sure my store's up you
know
it was a it was a tough that's brill man
i'm i'm so proud of what you've achieved
what was it that made you want to come
on this show why did you want to do this
i just i think there's a lot of people
out there
that want to do stuff differently
so i want to invest in property but they
don't know how to do it yeah
and they're a bit scared and
uh they don't know what step to take so
i just wanted to
kind of come here share share it with
everyone really and i
and tell them actually first and
foremost
um not what you want to do but then get
the
knowledge and get you know i just want
to share that story because i think
there's a lot of people that want to
change their lives but they're too
scared
they don't want to take that leap um or
you know they don't want to invest their
money just in case
you know things don't work out yeah but
i remember you said something in
in the crash course and actually in some
of your uh
in your youtube videos as well in
property
you can never fail which if you're
looking at long term
it's so true yeah but some more is
because people have to live somewhere
yeah you know i mean that's so true i
mean
the thing is with property is if you buy
bitcoin it could potentially turn to
nothing
but even if the house burns down you've
still got the land
which is still going to keep increasing
in value so it's probably one of the
safest investments you can ever make
well i'm so glad you did come down uh
your community as well you mentioned
that your community
are a bit sometimes skeptical or they've
got bad vibes when it comes to
investments and things tell me a bit
about that
yes i think i think there's the
skepticism in terms of actually
you know you know going into property
and you know sometimes you get the
property crash and then
like you said there's lots of bad vibes
are don't do that because it's not gonna
you know it's not gonna be beneficial or
you know
classic is pre-pandemic i mean when
pandemics died everyone thought
you know the property market was going
to crash and a lot of
my friends and family saying oh god you
know you've
you know i mean are you doing the right
things i'm like don't worry even if it
did crash
i'm not going to sell my property it's
going to jump back up again in a few
happened do you know what's funny though
i don't understand why everyone's so
worried about the crash because i'm i'm
excited for a crash because it means i'm
about to buy cheap houses
yes you know i'm excited for a crash and
the houses that i've got
i ain't gonna sell them anyway i'm just
gonna keep getting the rent so
the whole people's whole mindset is very
strange and that's why as you say
education's so important
what would you say to somebody then that
was considering stepping out was
considering coming down to one of our
training programs getting trained
getting educated but was unsure was on
the fence what was your advice just do
it
that is it just do it yeah because
you know the two days i had was so
beneficial
um and then when i started uh you know
putting stuff in action you know what i
learned
um and then i i think i was on about six
or seven properties and i think i then
messaged you to say
samuel this is what i've done is what
i've done um
because again i want that i want people
to know you know if if
if they just uh not think about
actually the risk and stuff like that in
terms of the
the bit around stepping up yeah and they
just do it
then i think it's it's not you know
and i respect you for telling me as well
because so many people you know they do
the training they're going to be really
successful and then they they'll hear
from them then
they only want to talk to me when they
when they want something
but the fact that you reached out and
said hey i've succeeded thank you for
supporting me at the beginning
and now you're here i really respect
that appreciate you coming out so so
much
um and hopefully we'll do another
interview in a year or two
when you've got 100 houses i mean who
knows where the future holds but mad
respect will be your final words of
advice
for anyone watching this that wants to
get started wants to be successful will
be your best
nugget you can give them right now i
think my best nugget is
educate yourself and definitely
definitely go to uh crash course and i'm
not just saying it because
you i'm sitting in front of you yeah um
you know even if you just
go to the crash course the amount of
information you get
the amount of nuggets you get you know
i i can't i can't i can't forget you
told me about liverpool and now i've got
most of my hands are in liverpool yeah
you know and you just told me you told
the whole group yes
but i went away you took action
respect there we go guys you heard it
here first in other words
stop watching youtube right now instead
click the link below come meet me and
i'll tell you about the next investment
area to be investing in
i'll share and hopefully you'll be one
of those people that take massive action
like thomas did
you'll become wildly successful and then
you'll be sat here in my lounge
and we'll be talking about your success
and reminiscing on your experience with
the training
i hope you enjoyed the interview i'm
sure you did please do me a massive
favor
smash the like button don't forget to
subscribe as well you can subscribe
right up here
i've been doing interviews like this
every week now for
years and you can see a lot more
interviews like this way over 100
you can check out the entire playlist up
here and of course
don't forget to get booked on to the
free property training programs
where you can learn to do the same
details thanks for watching i'll see you
next time